über die situation insbesondere der
innenstädte nach grüner spreche ich
jetzt mit gerd landsberg
hauptgeschäftsführer beim deutschen
städte- und gemeindebund herr landsberg
die krise der innenstädte ist doch
eigentlich gar kein corona problem
sondern besteht eigentlich schon seit
jahren wenn ich seit jahrzehnten und ist
durch corona doch nur beschleunigt
worden
das ist richtig aber eben deutlich
beschleunigt worden sonst hätte
sicherlich noch mehrere jahre gedauert
aber wenn wir jetzt mal uns die zahlen
anschauen
wir müssen damit rechnen dass
hunderttausend einzelhandelsgeschäfte
nicht wieder eröffnen oder schließen da
hängen 500.000 arbeitsplätze dran
und jeder weiß innenstadt oder auch
ortskern ist die seele einer stadt wenn
das weiter verödet ist das für die
menschen schlecht für die wirtschaft
schlecht aber ins büro für die
betroffenen städten und gemeinden stellt
aber dann bin ich noch mal nachhakt wir
haben es doch hier mit einer
strukturkrise zu tun
die kann man doch nicht dadurch
eindämmen indem man jetzt wie zum
beispiel der handelsverband deutschland
fordert da millionen wenn nicht
milliarden einfach hinein dürfte als
hilfsmittel
nein wir können das ohnehin aus meiner
sicht nicht kurzfristig lösen
die innenstadt von morgen oder von
übermorgen wird eine ganz andere sein
natürlich wird es da immer noch
einzelhandelsgeschäfte geben aber es
wird kultur geben es wird mehr wohnen
geben mehr kunst mehr handwerk mehr
bildung und ganz sicher auch mehr grün
und meerwasser wir haben ja noch das
zusatz problem dass unsere städte
insbesondere den heißen sommern immer
heißer werden darunter leidet die
aufenthaltsqualität das heißt wir müssen
einen dialog mit den bürgerinnen und
bürgern führen wie stellt ihr euch die
innenstadt der zukunft vor und dann muss
man projekte entwickeln und das umsetzen
alles nicht so einfach aber wir müssen
jetzt anfangen
weil wie gesagt die krise hat diese
dramatik beschleunigt sie haben gerade
eben den klimawandel angesprochen in der
tat gegen städte werden wie das klima
auch immer heißer und speichern ja auch
die wärme warum soll ich denn als bürger
überhaupt noch in die innenstadt fahren
und nicht lieber raus ins grüne wo ich
auch shoppingmeilen habt wo ich
erlebnisgastronomie habe und vielleicht
auch ein angenehmeres klima genau das
ist die gefahr dass der bürger sagt da
gehe ich gar nicht mehr hin
das was ich dort kaufen kann kann ich
online oder woanders kaufen im übrigen
ist es so heiß und unerträglich und da
müssen wir gegenhalten weil viele
menschen ja schon auch die innenstadt
suchen wir erleben das jetzt die korona
regeln werden gelockert die innenstädte
sind schon voll es gibt schon eine
sehnsucht sich in der innenstadt zu
treffen zu begegnen sich sicher zu
fühlen
nur die rahmenbedingungen sind eben nur
mäßig gut sie haben gerade eben das
online-shopping angesprochen das ist ja
in anführungsstrichen der größte gegner
der innenstädte ein vorteil beim
online-shopping ich kann das
hervorragend an meinem freien tag am
sonntag tun
sie fordern jetzt ja auch die
sonntagsöffnung für die innenstädte
wir haben ganz klar einen
wettbewerbsnachteil für den stationären
handel
der ist gebunden an ganz viele regeln
der online-handel hat 24 stunden am tag
7 tage die woche offen das wollen wir
gar nicht beschneiden
aber wir denken schon der online-handel
benutzt ja auch unsere infrastruktur die
lieferketten die depots dass auch der
online-handel sich finanziell beteiligen
muss an der infrastruktur deswegen
plädieren wir als deutscher städte- und
gemeindebund für eine paketversand
steuer die dann auch genutzt werden kann
um die innenstädte in einen besseren
zustand zu bringen das ist nicht ganz
einfach wir wollen ja auch dass der
stationäre handel online sich betätigt
deswegen könnten die das gegebenenfalls
mit der gewerbesteuer verrechnen das
wird nicht kurzfristig gehen aber wir
haben ein positives echo
jedenfalls von den großen parteien im
deutschen bundestag dass sie sich so
etwas vorstellen können dass eben auch
die großen plattformen wie amazon einen
beitrag für unsere städtische
infrastruktur leisten ist ja uns gerade
angesprochen sie treffen sich heute mit
den führen
der fraktions politikern im deutschen
bundestag und werde sicherlich darüber
das thema sonntagsöffnung reden was
bekommen sie dafür signale weil die
gewerkschaften und die kirchen lehnen
das ja nach wie vor kategorisch ab ja
das ist ein altes thema es ist ja auch
nicht ganz neu wir sagen ja auch nicht
es muss jetzt unbegrenzt immer sonntags
offen sein aber jetzt in der krise da
haben wir viele dinge geschafft wo man
früher gesagt hat das geht gar nicht
vielleicht sollte man da etwas
großzügiger sein und auch die
gewerkschaften müssen natürlich die
arbeitsplätze im auge haben
sonst haben sie keine leute die sie mir
vertreten können wir haben schon mal ein
bisschen über die aktuellen probleme der
innenstädte gesprochen und da möchte ich
noch mal auf ein thema zu sprechen
kommen das sind die finanzhilfen viele
kommunen viele bundesländern geben ja
momentan finanzspritzen für die
innenstädte alles einzelmaßnahmen und
der bund hilft zum beispiel dem galeria
kaufhof karstadt konzern mit einer heim
milliarden an finanzhilfen ist das
sinnvoll in solche projekte etwas zu
investieren oder sollte es nicht lieber
kleineren geschäften zu gute kommen also
aus meiner sicht muss das ziel sein das
berühmte einzelhandelsgeschäft zu
fördern das ist ja das fachgeschäft
genau das suchen die menschen die ketten
wird es immer geben aber sie haben nicht
die große zukunft und sie tragen auch
nicht dazu bei diesen flair zu schaffen
dem die menschen suchen
aber das ganze hängt natürlich insgesamt
auch an der finanzlage der städte und
gemeinden
wir werden in diesem jahr 9,5 milliarden
miese machen im nächsten jahr 10,5
gleichzeitig sollen die innenstädte
umbauen mehr für klimaschutz tun
energetische sanierung unserer gebäude
da werden wir ja heute eine diskussion
sicherlich führen mit den vertretern der
bundespolitik ob sie nicht doch dazu
verständigen können den kommunen
nochmals zu helfen wie das ja im letzten
jahr erfolgreich umgesetzt werden konnte
letzte frage finden fall dass es nicht
gelingen sollte die innenstädte zu
erhalten zu retten was wäre so schlimm
dran
also ich glaube die seele der städte und
gemeinden würden leiden und innenstädte
gibt es seit 1000 jahren und die wird es
weiter geben sie werden anders sein
also ich bin optimist ich glaube wir
schaffen das die menschen wollen dass
die politik will das und wir wollen das
auch dankeschön gerd landsberg
hauptgeschäftsführer des deutschen
städte- und gemeindebund herzlichen dank
nach berlin für dieses gespräch
bitteschön